In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for August 24, on which we commemorate the Holy Marjor
Uticus, disciple of Saint John the Theologian.
On the 24th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Marjor Uticus, disciple of
Saint John the Theologian.
Saint Uticus was baptized by Saint John the Theologian, whom he then followed on his travels.
Filled with the grace of the Holy Spirit, he preached the gospel with courage, throwing
down a number of temples of idol worship, and being beaten for it, enduring also bonds
and long years of imprisonment.
One day, when he was in prison, an angel appeared to him and brought him heavenly nourishment,
and he immediately found himself imbued with such divine strength that he remained unharmed
on being cast into a furnace.
He was then thrown to wild beasts, but to their great stupification, those present saw the
blessed martyr talking peacefully with them.
Having thus triumphed over all the trials by the grace of God, Saint Uticus returned to
his homeland, sabast, where he spent the rest of his days in peace.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.